Speaker 1: Hey, this is amazing. Lauren Boebert
radical and repugnant. Republican Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert. Apparently in her desire to
complete compete with Marjorie Trader, GREENE
is now going after wanton killing. I know I'm
saying that correctly in the sense of this is
how she said it. Preaching from a Bible verse.
Lauren Boebert didn't understand the word wanton
and instead attacked wanton killing, taking a
very forceful stand against Chinese dumplings.
Speaker 4: Then all hell broke loose.
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 4: It evil, grabbing and grasping,
vicious back stabbing. They made life hell on
earth with their envy, wanton killing. I don't
know what a wanton killing is. I would have to.
Speaker 1: Look that one up. It is hard to think
of a woman more dim sum. Sorry, a woman more
dim than Lauren Boebert is what I mean. This is
actually the thing Trump does. Trump does this
thing where he reads the speeches that someone
else wrote for him, and he reacts to them like
he's reading a news article Trump will say during
a speech. And it is once again Democrats who a
dozen times have acted to try to get us banned
from Twitter. That's true. That's actually true. I
didn't know that, but that's true. Hillary doing a
commentary on the speech, which makes it very
hard to believe that it's actually his words.
It's the exact same thing with Lauren Boebert.
One time killing. There's, by the way. You
know how I talk about this theme of these
right wingers who are incredibly confident
about things they're completely wrong
about. Here is Lauren Boebert explaining
to others the right way to say. Inalienable.
Speaker 4: We the people have been endowed
by our Creator with certain inalienable rights.
Speaker 1: That's inalienable is not from
any animal.
Speaker 4: I mean,
maybe these rights are unbelievable.
Speaker 1: They are unable to write.
Unalienable. That's a very, very important
declaration. So there's Lauren Boebert,
these people continuing to be visibly
confused at the things that someone
puts in front of them to write. And
it is quite a doozy. Quite a doozy.